and so Nikita said something in the
group message which he says I think it'd
be an interesting idea to ask myself or
to figure out you're making it too soft
I remember exactly how he said it it's
like oh so what are you doing what are
you up to nowadays oh Sam you sold the
hustle what are you doing shot on you so
what are you doing Nikita you're sitting
at Facebook what are you doing and he's
basically he just said it straight
straight up he goes
um I'm just thinking about how I can
make 10 million dollars in three months
like uh and if we're like what he's like
yeah I want to make an app that
generates like 10 million dollars in 90
days
[Music]
foreign
what's going on we have a good episode
we talk about an app that's going viral
but this app role is getting written
about a bunch of Publications we
actually have the inside story because
we kind of saw what was happening behind
the scenes early early on and so we
talked about this guy named Nikita who
launched this app that has made a
million dollars in like two weeks or
something crazy like that and we tell
you the inside story behind it what else
we got and he called his shot which you
know we love here we also talk about a
ransom note that we got through email
and why this Ransom note was one of the
best emails that we've ever got and me
and Sam live brainstorm and live
negotiate
how we're going to deal with this Ransom
note so if you want to see that that's
at the end of the episode we also talk
about the MailChimp CEO getting canceled
and a little debrief of Palmer lucky so
that's it enjoy this episode all right
we live Sam par what's up nothing how's
it going
uh you know just the usual woke up
decided okay no small boy stuff today
got going
immediately started considering some
small boy stuff and then I remembered
there will be absolutely none of that
today what was it I woke up I was like
I'm a little sore so wake up with a
complaint and wake it up with a
complaint on one of the greatest days
I've ever had wow this is this is not
how I'm going to start my day wait why
was it one of your greatest days uh just
like that's just like a general General
attitude I have uh do you want to start
off by recapping Palmer lucky because
after talking to him I feel like he's
kind of the greatest guy I've ever
talked kind of the man yeah right is
that how you feel I thought he was
awesome
um
okay let me just say a word that
describes Paul merloki I would say
um
like
independent-minded I think uh I think I
really respected that he is
independently minded I felt like all his
opinions were his own you know people
like they write that in their
Twitter bio like opinions are mine not
my employer uh you know his opinions are
really his uh also when people write
contrarian thinker and it's kind of like
if if you have to say that you're
contrarian thinker you're maybe not like
the most contrarian thinker
do you know what I mean right it's like
the no offense
I'm not gonna raise this butt yeah yeah
that's exactly what it is so I uh anyway
yeah I I thought that he was an
independent thinker I also thought that
he was incredibly enthusiastic which I
liked yeah very enthusiastic dead on the
inside like we have we have said no to a
bunch of guests just simply because
they're like you know their intelligence
is like cranked up to level 10 their
success is cranked up to level 12 but
they're like Charisma and ability to
convey any sort of enthusiasm about
themselves about the world about their
story is so low and um and so they make
for a terrible podcast guest but for him
it felt not only like did he have
Charisma to tell stories about the past
he seemed really pumped about what he
was doing and what the future looked
like and why it mattered and I just felt
like this guy you know just like Springs
out of bed every day
me too that's exactly how I felt I felt
like he was incredibly enthusiastic
about life and he yes that that's a
great way to explain it but he uh dude
he was so fascinating he was one of
those guys that I like because
I don't like I I can't think of a great
word to explain say other than like
prolific but also almost like this I
don't think this is over
explaining it or overgrandizing it but
like almost like a renaissance man where
he would say comments like yeah I bought
this Marina because there's going to be
new laws about I don't even understand
like what he was explaining about his
marina but he said like something about
his marina and like Seaport access and
how it's changing and then he made
another comment but he was like he's
like I was gonna do this well I mean
seastating is is off the table for now
and I was just like I don't even really
know what seastating is exactly and you
were just said it like well we all know
she's standing now is not the time
what are you talking about what the hell
is he saying yeah he also he also and
like he'll make another comment he's
like yeah I have this house we rented we
had like a a workshop and one weekend I
was building a jet engine for the water
and we actually discovered that like we
should make biodegradable or what did he
say we should make oil-based Foods it's
kind of like building a Diet Coke for
every food and I was just like we could
take this over lots of different paths
but it's just so interesting to me that
you have that ability yeah it was like
bunch of like candy being waved at us
he's just like you know one of the
largest samurai sword collections in the
world and that just got me into thinking
and it's like what
uh he didn't say that by the way but
there's at least a 50 chance he has one
of the top 10 samurai sword collections
in the world and 100 the guy owns swords
like yeah he definitely owned swords
um all right so where do you want to go
next you can drive all right so check
this out I forwarded you an email
did you uh see the email I sent from
about about Sarah's list or maybe maybe
she sent this to you too
what was it so a woman named Kristen uh
sends a um an email I'm just going to
read it to you we'll show it on the
screen you know for those on YouTube
because it's it's kind of amazing
looking oh my God you open up the email
and it says I am holding sarahslist.com
hostage and she goes you don't know me
but I obviously know you I purchased
sarah'slist.com and I've turned it into
a bomb ass website I am willing to sell
it to you for twenty thousand dollars
this is a steal as I purchased it for
thirty thousand dollars I'm essentially
giving you ten thousand dollars you're
welcome if you'd ever if you'd ever like
to see salesless.com again and then she
turned this font small or for the first
time
you know reply to this message I'm
looking forward to hearing from you
Kristen and I was just like this is
amazing who are you and um who is who is
she yeah so she's um this is this woman
Kristen Kent
so she sends me her story after that she
goes I've been in 12 tech for 12 years
um you know uh regrettably I chose
companies off Kristen's list which was
not as lucrative as if I had chose
companies off services so for those who
don't know Sarah's list is this concept
and we should explain we did a full
episode about it basically Sam's wife
Sarah is a self-made millionaire and did
not do any of the heroic entrepreneurial
things you hear about in the media she
just did one really good thing she just
picked companies whose Equity was going
to like whose valuation was going to go
up four or five x in a four year period
so she worked at Facebook and not early
at Facebook not like she was like
employee four at Facebook like she was
like in the thousands of employees
joined us like a middle middle manager
type not and again I say this not as
disparagement because of how amazing it
is so like she didn't do the things that
you think you have to do to become like
a self-made millionaire uh she joined
Airbnb again as employee I don't know
something hundred what was it maybe like
300 or 400 no a thousand oh a thousand
okay great and Airbnb goes public at
evaluation is four five x and so you
know if you're receiving a stock grant
for let's call it sixty thousand dollars
a year uh you know on top of your you
get you get some base Concepts I'm just
gonna use fake numbers base compensation
let's say is 150 and then they give you
50k of stock a year for for over four
years that's 200k of stock but now the
stock price four or five X's you made a
million dollars during that time period
um and you were safe you didn't have to
like work 90 hour weeks you uh got to
work at a fun growing company that was
gonna like win this category and you
didn't have to have this like amazing
lightning in a bottle genius idea in
order to do it and so she had done that
a few times and so we we said oh this
was actually intentional you and Sarah
sat down and you guys yeah we like made
lists we like made lists like what's
like a 500 person company that has good
maternity leave you know like these are
all like the telltale signs that it's
like an interesting startup has uh
you're in the you know top quartile of
pay just for off salary you have uh
interesting benefits good health care
like all this stuff that a lot of
startups that are early don't have but
big companies do yet they can still 5 or
10x so yeah we made that list so we made
the list and of the we put 12 companies
on that list this was like a year year
and a half ago now 12 companies on that
list and I think we did the the recap I
don't remember the exact numbers but I
think the in the year year and a half
since then the average company values up
like two and a half X or something crazy
like that and an 11 out of the 12
companies raised a like significant up
round since then so we were like very
high hit rate and if you got in whatever
your stock value would have been at that
time I think on average it's something
like two and a half X
um could be wrong I don't remember the
math uh but and so this lady sets a site
by the way and I'm looking at it this is
amazing but her email is she so she dm'd
me on Twitter and so whenever people DM
me on Twitter I either ignore them or I
just like click the heart emoji like
thank you I recognize you but I don't
want to talk and that's what I did with
her and I just replied and said I'm an
idiot this is you're actually you're
different different yeah
this is a really good one so okay so
then here's what I want to do so you go
to the website it's just sarahslist.com
it says 12 startups that can make you a
millionaire it's got a picture of Richie
Rich which is hilarious and then it goes
who is Sarah who are we and why do we
have any business sharing a list like
this and then it tells the story about
Sarah about us whatever selection
criteria it uses our criteria which is
that it's a company that's already
valued over 250 million dollars so it
has a low risk profile and it's likely
not going to go to zero a stable work
environment a high salary great benefits
but still can make you a millionaire
because the equity has potential to 5 to
10x and then it has our list which was
like flexport and uniswap and Andrew and
replit and airtable and figma like figma
got acquired for whatever 20 billion or
something like that but more than that
uh you know after we uh after we
mentioned it on this list when it was
that's like a 10x I think from where we
mentioned it so anyways uh then it says
find a friend a job so you go to the job
board and it goes these are placeholder
jobs you guys should consider syncing
this up to one of these websites but
those cost money which is why and the
last job post says I'm not doing it And
the tagline so the tagline at the bottom
says Sarah's list get rich in five to
ten years over 50 guaranteed yeah
exactly so hilarious so then I started
thinking okay
so I said let's brainstorm this live
here on the podcast
should we do this deal and no uh and
okay so your opinion is no and give me
why no here's why it's just a a website
that would take me five minutes or no it
would take me oh it's a website that
take me three hours to copy and a domain
name so for that reason it's not that
valuable but what's more valuable is
this lady uh Kristen who's making it
yeah her email exactly are are beautiful
her copies beautiful her I just looked
at her Twitter this woman uh Kristen is
the exact type of people that I like to
be around she also works at xpa which uh
Expo is basically a company founded by
the founder of uber Garrett I think is
it Garrett Camp yeah and they basically
are a startup Studio that launches
companies I don't actually know any of
the companies that they've launched but
I imagine a lot of them are really
successful but she works there which is
also a really good like indicator that
she's like onto something uh do I think
that we should buy this absolutely not
do I think that I want this woman in my
life and would love to work with her in
some capacity 100
agreed the real value here is not the
domain it's not the website it's Kristen
Kent okay so here's my here's my
proposal to Kristen Kent here's my
counteroffer uh my public podcast
counter offer to you Kristen
I'll give you the twenty thousand
dollars I'll give it to you in fact I'll
give you the thirty thousand dollars
that you paid for this uh this domain if
you really paid that much for this
domain I mean that's kind of crazy and
uh but it comes with this catch
we're going to work together on this
project
you're going to do the work on the on
the company side and I'm going to do the
work on the promotional side the
distribution side
and here's what we're going to do with
Sarah's list
we're going to turn Sarah's list into a
half a million dollar a year passive
income stream ah passive-ish I should
say pass it for me that's a little
active for you but Anyway by the way
Sean when you say we gotta let's
remember this is Sarah's list of which I
am 50 of Sarah's list so whatever Sam is
is on the side right now Sam said no no
no no no no no no
a moment ago and he's not a part of the
counter offer Sarah herself will get a
one percent royalty as we use her name
here's what we gotta do what what per
what percentage of the of the of the
dividends would you give or would you
want Kristen to have
Kristen deserves 50. she deserves 50 I
agree the the other 50 split you and I
split and 90 10 you got it sir
so the other share the royalty with
Sarah so
here's what we're gonna do actually
I don't know if I even want to say this
this deal now that we're having these uh
this is this intense negotiation I want
to give out my great idea okay I'll give
up my great idea so here's the great
idea here's how we're going to make this
work so normally a job this is like
monetized as a job board right it would
be a list of companies that we are
curating saying these companies are
great and let's say we might take it to
24 25 companies
um rather than the 12 we have today and
normally on a job board you pay like 500
a post
um for for job posting so we would need
to go reach out to those companies get
them to post
the other thing uh you know but but hey
this is maybe premium it's a curated job
board maybe we could charge more maybe a
thousand maybe two thousand dollars to
be be posting your jobs on here
so if we got people to do that you know
let's say two thousand dollars a month
24 companies let's say half half of them
actually do it you know that's like 24K
a month not bad but I think we're going
to be in this kind of constant sales
Outreach period so let me put out a
different idea
here's a different idea
we're going to take these companies and
we're going to host a demo day once a
quarter what's that what's gonna happen
at the demo day we're gonna basically
um each week we're gonna feature one of
these companies we're gonna create an
email list we're gonna spin off our
current email list and we're gonna say
we're gonna feature one of these
companies we're gonna do Deep dive but
why this company is a good company to
work for
and interested people you know high
quality people in Tech might well that
needs to be an upsell that needs to be
an upsell it's where it's like for 25 25
000 like you get a deep dive as a
minority owner I'm not sure you have a
say here so
I could barely hear your voice it was so
faint like your Equity ownership of this
um so so if we're in the same room do
you think I would have hit you already
or or will that be coming in the next
will that be coming in the next 10
minutes or would it have already have
happened
so so you know the way you promoted
hustlecon where you used to write these
kind of blog posts once a week I think
you would you would feature the speaker
of hustlecon and you would tell their
story in this awesome infographic and
then you would say do you like stories
like this you should come to hustlecon
we're gonna have 25 badass entrepreneurs
including this person speaking there and
you should attend and you did that for
12 like 25 weeks and you sold out like
500 tickets to this thing so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do that once we
weak Cadence about these companies do a
little deep dive that's the email and
then it's going to get people to attend
the the hiring day and hiring day is
where the founder of those companies
gonna come and they're going to give a
little five minute flash presentation on
their company and it's going to be a
cure and applicants apply to join and
these are you got to be good to joins
that's why we got to keep the quality
high on the company side and the
applicant side and then we're not
charging for a job posting we take the
like the recruiter fee because when a
recruiter places a candidate one of
these companies they take 20 or 30 000
right away and so if we could place like
25 candidates in a year
at twenty thousand dollars a pop you're
talking half a million dollars of of
Revenue which is basically all we have
to do is hire a writer we're gonna hire
a Ghost Rider who's just going to write
these company deep Dives on the
companies that we select have you heard
of the daily uh it was called The Daily
muse now it's called The Muse the
muse.com have you ever heard of that
company
the muse.com no I don't think so what's
that all right it was like a women's
hiring thing was that yeah yeah it was
it's called the muse.com it's been
around now for 10 years and the woman
who started I've been actually dming
I've been wanted to come on here yeah
she went to Duke too oh did Catherine I
think her name is yeah uh and so she
went to YC and so I actually originally
thought they that this was a great idea
but they screwed it up by raising a lot
of money and I think they've raised 20
30 40 50 tens of millions I don't know
the exact number but basically that what
they would do is they would do these
deep Dives on companies and charge the
company some like fairly big fee to do a
deep dive on the company and they
somehow got tons of traffic now they're
still getting eight million people a
month coming to their website or six
million something like that and they had
tons of people coming to their website
from search which is incredibly valuable
and I thought that they like were just
chugging along but like not doing that
great because I hadn't heard about them
I have a feeling they actually might be
killing it because they've raised a lot
of money and they actually are starting
to buy other companies at this point and
they do these deep Dives on companies
and another guy who does this is packing
McCormick and I have no idea what he
charges for this anymore but when the
economy was crushing it I think he was
charging 25 to 50 000 more per Deep dive
I think it was how much do you think it
was a little more I remember he was
making a hundred thousand a month if I
recall correctly off his deep Dives and
I think he might have been doing one or
two a month wow that's pretty amazing
and so I think you could do something
like that milk Road by the way we do a
deep dive thing and it's like I don't
know I forgot what it would cost I think
it's like it's like something between 25
and 40K depending on on the total like
promotion and who do you hire to do that
uh I wrote the first few because like we
have one of our writers wrote it and I
like kind of like changed it big time
but now we are hiring a writer just to
do the Deep Dives how much would you pay
a writer to do that
um a couple Grand a month like two grand
a month
per deep dive like I'll pay you 2002.
one article
so this is the value is not in the
writing the value is in that we have a
huge list and that if we promote
something to this huge list you're going
to get a bunch of of traction or you're
going to get usage or you're going to
get candidates or whatever it is so the
writer is not bringing the value the
writer just needs to deliver value but
the the list is what the list size is
why you can charge that much
yeah it's pretty fascinating I think
this is a really interesting business
I've always said I mean I'm the one who
even turns you on to job boards aren't I
so like you know new email
[Laughter]
and Sarah so and before me you weren't
even into.com so like you're welcome so
uh I think kudos to Kristen I think
she's on to something well I think we're
on to something but uh she also it seems
pretty special like I said if you want
if you want a side hustle that'll make I
don't know 250k a year for you uh it's
there for the taking uh I think that's
understandable all you got to do is all
the work
yeah but we'll we'll promote it here uh
this is an interesting thing uh I don't
think this is an event venture-sized
business which is I I guess why expert
isn't going after it but it maybe could
be uh it was a business back in the day
that went through YC called developer
auction do you remember this no but that
sounds a little weird that's not very
weird in a great way so basically what
they did was they were like no dude
that's not a good auctioning humans
doesn't exactly have the best branding
that's why it was great okay guys a head
turner and uh and you know when you're a
small company you need to be a head
turner and so um so these guys basically
they realized they were like wait the
power Dynamic is off why is it all about
applying to jobs when actually like the
developer is like the most valuable like
developer was like gold in Silicon
Valley and so they said why don't we
just curate like the top developers so
like who are these 10x engineers
and then let's just have them almost
like a beauty pageant they walk down the
stage and and the companies are like
raising their paddle I guess that's not
what happened to the beauty pageant but
like an auction where the the companies
were raising the paddle be like I'll
give them 300 000. I'll give them 400
000 I'll do his laundry and then
someone's like you know all sucking poop
and it's like you know that's basically
like the companies were like just
falling over themselves trying to get
this talent and so they did one and it
was amazing it was like you know 50
Engineers or whatever and all the
engineers got this huge pay jump from
these top companies they're like oh
that's awesome and then it built this
little flywheel where they're like the
next batch of really great developers
are like yeah yeah dude you're gonna do
all the work for me to like get me my
next job offers awesome all I got to do
is just go and explain how like yeah I
helped scale Netflix's like video
infrastructure so that you know we got
this latency in this blah blah blah
um so they would just go explain what
they did and then the companies would
bid and it was kind of a great idea I
thought they eventually it but the
problem is it wasn't going to scale up
it was like too almost Boutique and so
in order to scale up they changed the
model and then ended up pivoting into
something else altogether but like if
you just kept it Boutique which again
you you can't do this if you raise a
bunch of venture money because then your
expectations to go huge but if you're
like if you like making you know a
million dollars you know a year of like
passive income you could do that with a
boutique model like this just by
basically creating a demo day but
instead of startups pitching investors
you have you have companies pitching to
top talent and so you could just if
you're good at curating right if you're
a good curator right we we did a good
job creating on the company side now you
just got to do a good job creating on
the talent side you could actually
create a pretty solid side hustle here
do you enjoy working with your wife
no
I uh there are enjoyable things but
there are also some very unenjoyable
things I but I tell you this on
everything if we have to like assemble
some like Ikea furniture I'm like I hate
doing projects with you and like because
like we're both we're both too stubborn
we both want our way and I'm like why
don't you just listen and she's like why
don't you just listen I'm like because I
don't want to listen and she's like
I uh so I've been I'm I'm coming out I'm
gonna do the ideation boot camp again
and I um
was trying to convince Sarah to like
quit her job and like do this and it
ain't happening we like did we did a few
test trials and we cooked dinner
together and yeah it didn't work out
like it just like me talking to her like
were co-workers just just doesn't work
yeah that's exactly the problem I talked
to her like I would talk to somebody
who's like you know somebody you know on
my team at my startup and she's just
like why are you speaking to me like
this and I'm like well but I'm not in
husband mode right now I mean like yeah
yeah it modes his modes yeah it's just
like I would be like look you're not
stupid but this is stupid and she'd be
like why are you talking to me like this
I'm like what do you mean I'm I'm trying
to encourage you and like don't you want
to like climb up this organization's
ladder like don't you want to be great
and Achieve great things and she's like
just wants to punch me in the stomach
back the wind out of me I'm like yeah I
don't know if this is gonna work yeah I
wanted this to work but I don't think
this can happen so I I I don't know how
the couples do it but uh it wasn't
working for us there were many great
examples like uh the founders of
Eventbrite were that's a husband and
wife couple uh the founders of bibo back
in the days Yoshi and Michael burst
their husband wife couple they were
together just great and uh yeah but I
think it needs like that complimentary
personalities where one
and also like I don't have the best
bedside manner you know it was a shocker
like you know pretty direct and pretty
blunt about stuff
um and I you know I don't have that
thing that some people have going for
them I think you have this where you
could just be hella blunt and it's like
it's a Sam being Sam like uh you know
you know he's got it he gets to play by
his own rules because that's just the
way he is I have uh like I have too much
finesse in my game like if you have if
you have no finesse people are like he's
got no finesse it's fine like he's just
being blunt don't take it seriously but
if you have any then it's like oh he
could have said that differently but he
chose to say it the wrong way and you
don't get the you don't get that like
that you know that pass to just like you
know say things you know the wrong way
earlier in the episode we said you would
describe uh Palmer Lucky in one word and
you I think you know we both said
different things if I had to describe
the this last 60 Minute episode in one
word I would say
exhausting this was an exhausting I I
feel like I just went on like a journey
with you and I need to go rest my eyes
is that how you feel I'm just getting
stronger by the minute
dude that I believe that's called
anti-fragile you and I are not the same
yeah you and I are absolutely not the
same Where Do We Go From Here do we end
it here or do we keep going I want to do
two little things one all right I just
want to have a moment of silence for the
MailChimp CEO
what happened he got wait the MailChimp
CEO or the founder uh Ben Ben
who was this what happened though I
think right he was I think he quit when
they sold it so I don't know exactly
benches benches down
so okay so so MailChimp was this like
darling they were bootstrapped I think
they were Butch up forever then they
sold to Intuit for many billions of
dollars like they did it for like 20
years and they did it out of like
Atlanta so they were like this Indie
success story right like they're like
you know like there's like hundreds of
Indie hackers right now on
indiehackers.com that like by the way
you said Atlanta in a very funny way
it's kind of like I usually say Detroit
you just said Atlanta you put a you put
a hard a t on that obviously and I like
that Atlanta
ah okay well
you know it's like Detroit Detroit
Atlanta
so this guy he had to step down so he
goes um so did you see what what he did
or what happened so he sent a
um so he sent like an email or something
like that where is it let me pull up I
see it yeah he basically just said uh
he's uh he basically uh said Chestnut
said he identified a dangerous Trend in
his Workforce new hires introducing
themselves using their preferred
pronouns this is completely unnecessary
for a woman who is clearly a woman to
tell us her pronouns as she her and a
man who is clearly a man to tell us that
his pronouns are he him he wrote in an
email uh to a small group of employees
uh instead Chestnut said he understood
the practice was rooting kindness but
added that in the long run this approach
just more harm than good forcing people
to behave in certain ways that are the
opposite of inclusion okay sounds not
horrible but uh that's a dangerous
dangerous path to go down by the way my
recommendation to all of us is to just
not comment on this I think we should
just read it what happened and then a
moment of silence for for uh for for
this guy for getting fired from
basically fired oh I stepped down
coincidentally right after this uh but
you know for for you know whether you
agree with him or disagree with them I
kind of feel like having to step down is
a pretty like severe penalty having to
step down from your own company is a
pretty severe penalty for like having a
point of view on this stuff but like
maybe that's like maybe it's a lot more
severe than I think I don't know like
well what's great I think that when you
look at when you think about these
things words aren't just words you have
to look at intentions right and his
intention if you we don't even have to
read it but his intention is not to say
that anyway his intentions are good his
intentions actually I think are rooted
in like I want to make everyone feel
included and I want to be productive and
I you know whatever uh and I'm just
reading this email a little bit like
here's live and so it doesn't seem like
a negative email here's the part where I
think it got diceyform so he goes in the
email he goes um first there was a tiny
number of peeps at MailChimp strange to
use peeps maybe that's like what they
call themselves is that like a chimp
word yeah so there's a very tiny number
of peeps at MailChimp who consider
themselves transgender forcing either
with orders or through guilt the
approximately 1300 other peeps to adopt
a new communication Paradigm that
Humanity has never had to use in our 300
000 years of existence and under 150 000
years of spoken language in order to
make things slightly more comfortable
for an extremely small group of peeps is
completely illogical and he says that if
you're forced to do something illogical
eventually you will believe and do
anything even if it's vicious okay
that's like a little like
he says now nowadays everything is
incredibly politicized I'm finding that
Peeps are no longer motivated by
meaningful work they're motivated to
make political statements they're using
company time and Company resources to
win a game against their opponents in a
game that is Raging in their minds and
on social media
um understanding and respecting that
people can have different different
views as part of being American part of
being mature adults peeps of all
different uh political leanings are free
to vote the way they want blah blah blah
but it's not for the workplace
so that's what he said
um I'll leave it to anybody to agree or
disagree my personal opinion is uh
I understand what he's trying to say I
think he said it in a pretty stupid way
like it's a little too aggressive
um and using the word peeps when you're
talking about these things is also like
if I I I I agree with the sentiment here
but I think that if I if it were a hot
button issue I wouldn't use slang yeah
you can't be like to the homies that had
to use the yeah
I guess internally they must just always
you that use that like you know like
Facebook had like whatever like and now
has like metamates or whatever like dude
it's kind of a meta mate to use a
pronoun is like there's two words that I
hate using in a serious like argument or
discussion like if I'm talking to Sarah
my wife or like someone else about like
look like you know they said this in
their tweets like if it's ever like the
word Tweets in an argument like did well
I tweeted did you see the Tweet did you
see their tweets you know what I mean
like I know
well he tweeted it like I don't want to
use that word or text
yeah like when I'm having a serious
conversation I want to talk about
something and I got to use well he
tweeted that you see his tweets yeah
because it's too much
yeah it doesn't sound I'm not a fan but
yeah I'm gonna add peeps to that list so
yeah rip Ben I like Ben I don't know him
I'm acting like I do uh I've called the
emailed him a ton of times and he's
never replied to me but uh so we kind of
know each other so and it's like so
karma yeah
I guess he's just one of those peeps
yeah he doesn't reply to my emails you
can see what happens for those peeps
yeah he's he's him in a six billion can
go off and be unhappy by themselves but
uh you know whatever uh I like Ben
chasma Chestnut I love MailChimp I think
it's a great company yeah um me too I
think MailChimp is a cool really cool
success story
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
do you uh do you want to talk about
Nikita
uh yeah we kind of did but it seemed
like I know but we've lost it over I
think so at the end of a podcast a few
days ago the Sean Story one we talked
about this guy Nikita beer who you and I
are both friends with but we talked
about it at the end of like an hour
session and I realized this is actually
really amazing and deserves a
significantly more time and so I'll kind
of give yeah so Nikita beer he's our
good friend we're in a group text
message uh with him and that's actually
how I got to know him and everything I'm
going to explain most everything is
public information so this is like
through articles and it's Twitter feed
so I'm not gonna say anything that is
confidential but basically he started an
app called TBH so he went to school in
Berkeley California started an app
called TBH which was basically uh some
type of like viral High School app that
like you could answer questions about
your peers something like that no it
wasn't incredibly significant of an app
but it went viral and got millions of
users very quickly after him spending
over two years trying to create viral
apps and so we kind of I felt like he
kind of honed in on what works and more
importantly what doesn't work Facebook
eventually buys the app for tens of
millions of dollars originally it was
said to be like 100 million I think in a
recent article they're like it was
actually like 40 million which is still
a great outcome and that was about five
years ago and so Nikita said something
in the group message which he says I
think it'd be an interesting idea to ask
myself or to figure out you're making it
too soft I remember exactly how you said
it it's like oh so what are you doing
what are you up to nowadays so Sam you
sold the hustle what are you doing Sean
you still be what are you doing Nikita
you're sitting at Facebook what are you
doing he's basically he just said it
straight straight up he goes
um I'm just thinking about how I can
make 10 million dollars in three months
like uh and if we're like what and he's
like yeah I want to make an app that
generates like 10 million dollars in 90
days
and we talked about that like that's
just crazy that's outlandish we brought
it up on this podcast but it was a
really interesting we just thought of it
as an interesting thought exercise like
oh that's actually a really backwards
from that dream okay if that's is that
possible yeah it is possible I guess it
is possible so that all right I'm a
smart guy let me find out find out a way
I would do it it's obviously very
challenging and so I guess he must have
had I don't actually don't know if this
is true or not but I imagine when you
sell a company to Facebook you have some
type of non-compete well typically not
competes are anywhere from two to five
years the other day a few months ago it
was the end of uh the five year period
since selling tbh and so I imagine that
was the period where he was like great I
can do that and so he launches this app
about three months ago where basically
you like you it's the same app as TBH so
what was tbh tbh was a Anonymous polling
app or compliments app so you I don't
know if you remember like in high school
there would always pass this thing
around the end of the year the the
superlatives test and it would be like
who is most likely to become a famous
you know famous in Hollywood oh this
person in our school who is most likely
to you know end up with with 10 kids or
whatever right you just come up with
these like future looking things who's
the best who's got the best smile this
person wins best smile and so TBH was
that because he was playing on this
thing which is people are very
interested in them themselves and and
the people around them and so you're
like all right if I I'll go through and
I'll answer this quiz and it was using
it like so that sounds very simple under
the hood it's got to be pretty smart
right because it's got a surface in your
contacts it's going to surface the right
four or five names that you actually
know who do you actually know so you
could pick you know your friends and um
and then they would send them a text
message and saying hey Sam somebody said
that you have you have the best smile in
your school download the app to find out
who who said it and you're like 100
you're gonna go find out who said I have
the best smile or who said I'm most
likely this who said they have the
biggest crush on me and so you know that
Taps into like something pretty deep in
a teenager and so that's what TBH was
got acquired
um and by the way that same idea had
been done many many times our buddy
suley who was the first episode of the
podcast he had built that same
superlative idea as a Facebook app when
the Facebook app platform launched back
in like 2007 or something and it also
went by it also went crazy viral like
this is is just an idea that goes viral
and you can switch he did it on the
Facebook app platform Nikita did it on
the mobile platform where you would send
SMS uh you know invites based off of
this and so it's the same that was what
he did then it got acquired immediately
pretty much immediately got shut down uh
there wasn't really much retention in it
and so it was like oh that's a cool idea
it gets people engaged goes viral for a
short period of time but there's no
engagement all right so there's no
long-term retention seems like it gave
him this like this Persona of like I am
a I'm a wonderkin like I know how to
make things go viral because a
it is partially true and B Nikita kind
of has this like aura about him that who
knows if it's on purpose or not on
purpose where he like is mysterious and
like somewhat silent and only make
sarcastic jokes and everything comes
easy to him like that's like his like
cool kid demeanor yeah yeah he
definitely definitely tries to be a cool
kid all right so then
it's a app you open up it says who do
you have a crush on who's got the best
smile who's most likely to be whatever
who would you trust to bail you out of
jail uh and you you answer and they're
all supposed to be you know sort of like
pop more positive-ish questions or not
it's not like mean it's not supposed to
be bullying and uh again starts to go
viral and so we sat there in this group
chat as it was happening so describe
kind of how it played out from your
perspective he says things like all
right now we're adding a thousand people
an hour and I kind of brush that off
because like I think maybe these are
just Bots like this isn't actually
serious well there's one little
difference he launches it and we're like
cool man how do we download the app he's
like you have to it's geofenced to these
three high schools in Georgia and we're
like what and he's like and we're like
hey and then he would post like a CH
like you know he'd be like post this
Graphics it's going viral but it's got
like 200 people we're like oh only 200
he's like there's only like 2 000 people
in the school this is going to take away
like like right away but it uses like
academic language like it has a k Factor
or a blank but we're seeing that user
retention stagnates at this thing the
turn happens at three percent like it
was density
that's cool and then and then he goes
then he's supposed to chart and we're
like oh sick like I don't like how come
I don't see it when I go to my App Store
chart like you know social free apps
he's like we put it in the games
category under puzzles he's like he's
like that way we're gonna like stay away
from competition until we flip the
switch and we're like whoa like damn
this guy is like this is like if you
want Game of Thrones and they're talking
about like you know how to invade King's
Landing it's like these guys standing at
this giant table moving these chess
pieces around like talking about
conquering that's him but the chess
pieces are like high schools and he's
moving them yeah it was like uh it's
like James Bond villain of High School
uh you know quizzes if that's such a by
the way there's one key twist to the
whole thing
it's TBH again but he's like this time
we're not trying to be the next Snapchat
we don't care about the retention we're
just gonna put a in-app purchase that
says pay to see who voted for you and
he's like they're gonna pay and we're
like well I get well will they pay
they're gonna pay and it's like the
thing is a freaking 699 Weekly
subscription so this is basically 28 a
month this is double the price of
Netflix to see who voted for you and
he's like yep so if we're converting you
know whatever four percent of people and
we can take over this state Georgia
Georgia high schools each high school
has this many students and yeah 1.8
million dollars a month okay good yeah
let's go that's basically like my
reenactment of how they're thinking
about this and at this with TBH he had
raised a little bit of money he had
raised money from Founders for on Fund
in Greylock and like the the when you do
that it says uh you know you I've got to
build the next Snapchat this way with
this new company he just basically says
dude I'm self-funded I've got 400
Engineers living in my La house right
now we're just trying to like make it
big make it fast and uh what do they say
on South Park like uh scale up no start
up get big cash out bro down you know
like that like that's exactly what he's
trying to do he's trying to just get in
get the bag get out and just maybe
return two idea for you yeah not uh and
so anyway about 10 days after it
launches I'm just making these numbers
up but it's around a week maybe two
weeks
he starts saying like oh man people are
starting to spread these rumors that
this app is being used for human
trafficking and we laugh that off and he
goes so I changed it to no he was like
he's like yeah it's like annoying like
as hell like we're getting a bunch of
deletions okay oh it's gonna die and we
were like what the thing that like you
called your shot you're like I'm gonna
build an app that goes viral it's gonna
make 10 million dollars in like 90 days
and that's a ludicrous thing to say
you spend like two years plotting he
went through a bunch of different ideas
to think about what it could be decides
you know what it's TBH with a paywall
launch it like spends you know it has
these like seven Engineers living in his
living room you know the place smells
like you know Ramen and Old Spice and
he's like all right we build the app
after a few months we launched this
thing in these pockets of Georgia it
goes viral but then this whole you know
this hoax starts saying this is for I
don't know what the sex trafficking
human sex trafficking which I didn't
even understand but I didn't even
understand but I shouldn't even say
those words YouTube's gonna like
de-prioritize this algorithm like and
we're out of the algorithm now like
because I said that out loud and he says
that he's like well it's actually it's
just like a couple reviews but I have a
feeling that these couple of reviews are
gonna like spread someone already made a
video on Tick Tock this is just how
things work and so I'm like it's
whatever like that I don't understand
that entirely that sounds like you're
just being like neurotic but sounds good
so he changes the name to crush right
yeah so app starts getting deleted or no
it gets taken down in the App Store
Apple takes down or something like that
he's like oh we're gonna petition blah
blah we're gonna re-upload as
crush and he sends us hey guys like new
brand
and it looks
exactly like yeah exactly like crush the
soda like like the grape flavor
it sends it in the text and I I got so
thirsty like you know like the pavlovian
dog response I saw that and I was like I
need orange soda on my tongue right now
and uh I hadn't had orange soda in like
a decade if I saw that thing and I was
like I need that relaunches again in
like you know Alabama this time he's
like okay we're going south and they
attacked Alabama with their four High
School launch strategy they do they have
this like thing set to a T and by the
way like he had he had wrote a memo
inside Facebook once about how TBH was
launching high schools effectively he's
like we created basically his theory is
basically for a social app the most
valuable thing you can have is a
reliable way to test your app so like
can you get this into a a small Network
like like a high school where most
people know each other or know of each
other of a thousand people quickly
because if you could do that you could
test it in one high school see what the
data says and then you could tweak the
app launch in another High School do it
again he's like that reliable like petri
dish to test in is the most valuable
thing so they had come up with a
strategy which was they put this memo
got leaked when he was at Facebook which
was like they would create Instagram
accounts like you know Crush
you know
um you know archipelago High you know
and it's like they they take the high
school name and they take the brand name
of the thing and they would make the
account private and they would go follow
every kid who had like you know class of
whatever 2022
um in that high school they would follow
all of them so then the kid would say
who followed me uh it has my high school
name in it they click it it's private to
find to see the profile you've got to
follow back so they would they would
request to follow so a whole bunch of
people requested to follow he's like but
we would not accept anyone and it's like
this is like you know the Dennis system
on all of a sudden he's like you know
first we demonstrate value then we take
it away and he's like then at 4 pm on
the day before launch which uh the day
of the launch when everybody gets out of
school you know we have a guy in a truck
watching people leave the school as soon
as they do we hit accept requests we
accept everybody's request everybody
gets a notification at the same time and
then they go to it the bio basically
says download the app see who likes you
you download the app and then he's like
we would instantly go with Ireland in
high school so he had this like launch
strategy which which was I thought
pretty pretty great pretty tactical so
he's doing that again now with crush
crush gonna go it's gonna launch like
that and it starts to work and we're
like wow dude you did it again like the
first one wasn't a fluke you did it
again all of a sudden it totally
attracted a different demographic
because of this like stupid Orange Soda
logo and the name crush and so he's like
oh God you know to cut all right let's
move the scene around change the name
again and he comes back for act three
and this time it's called gas and by the
way this hole so he'd been working on
this for many months maybe more than a
year I don't know but this whole thing
that we're describing takes place over
two to three weeks and it gets to the
point where he starts making up phrases
like uh we are acquiring new users at
this rate per hour you know a lot of
times we talk about saying like ARR
annual recurring revenue and what a lot
of companies will do is they'll take
like their monthly run rate and multiply
that by 12 to say this is what they're
doing he was basically doing that at a
per hour base so he's like oh we're you
know we're we're acquiring a thousand
users per hour which means our uh our
rate of like a new users is like 365
million whatever and yeah he was like
he's like if you look Dawn day over day
it's like
you're just measuring the period of like
the sunrise day over day what's your
what your numbers are that's insane and
so gas starts like taking off similar to
the original one but this time even even
more and in a matter of like seven days
I believe he starts tweeting out the
results and letting us know and
basically within like seven days give or
take five days I don't know exactly it
was doing a million daily it had a
million daily users was adding 30 000
new users an hour users were answering
3.2 million polls per hour in a brown
like 10 days I believe he's hit a
million dollars in sales and are also
around 10 days in it was number one in
the App Store and he had been telling us
it's going to be number one in the next
handful of days it's gonna be number one
and they totally called it and we're
talking number one like
above Tick Tock above Instagram above
Facebook yeah totally this is all true
and he said he tweets out he goes ladies
and gentlemen after a five-year Hiatus
I'm no longer a one-hit wonder
introducing gas the number one app in
the app store and this is when it turns
to the point where it's incredibly hard
for us to compliment him and a root for
him because clearly this guy has a chip
on his shoulder clearly for the last
five years he was mad that he sold too
soon or didn't become like huge or
didn't become wealthier or didn't become
whatever his his Target was but he fell
short it felt like and now he's proving
that he is the man because here's what's
hap here's what here's what starts
happening and he gets hilariously cocky
about it which I I I love I love I love
it makes me like him even more but I
love and so like here's an example a
really popular VC tweets out uh his name
is Josh Gelman momentum growth is a
powerful feeling and it could also go
away really quickly I have been
surprised I have been surprised how many
things with seemingly Unstoppable
momentum have slow crawl this past year
zooming out growth without deep duration
adoption and habits doesn't count and
Nikita replies just at me and so
basically he just starts going around
anyone online on Twitter who's a big
shot who starts talking about high
growth stuff Nikita just pops out and
said what are you talking about me and
it's hilarious it is so funny and so
Abram this time though the rumors start
happening again about human trafficking
and he starts tweeting and sharing the
craziest stuff and this gets so big that
Ashton Kutcher is retweeting who Ashton
Kutcher didn't entirely know this but
like his whole like philanthropy thing
is human trafficking and so these rumors
of human trafficking start happening
again and Ashton Kutcher retweets Nikita
and says something like Nikita sends us
a screenshot it's Ashton Kutcher DM
again and he's like he just he's just
screenshotting us these like big shot
people that are just dming him like wink
face
instead of even saying hi they're just
like it's like is this how this guy like
slides into DMS that's interesting that
wasn't Ashton Kutcher but like uh but
Ashton also retweeted it I'd love to
meet I'd love to meet you I'd love to
help you know uh this thing is a hoax
because basically what Nikita is saying
is he's like the scene is taking off
like you wouldn't believe that you know
it's going viral the K factor is two and
then K factors too what that means is
for every person who joins you know
virally they invite two more right so
it's like you know you thought covid
spread fast watch how fast the gas app
is gonna spread it's got a a incredibly
High uh viral coefficient that just
basically means for free it's gonna take
over whatever demographic it is until
that until that coefficient starts to go
down because either it's saturated or
hits a new market where it's less viral
and so it's going viral
um ashcrutcher's like I'll help you try
to fight these hoax rumors because on
tick tock on Snapchat you just see story
after Story of somebody saying guys uh
delete this gap gas app it's suss as
hell I downloaded it and a white van
started following me around my
neighborhood
and people are like oh my God oh my God
share share just keep it keep our sis
like our school safe uh and it's like
girls like girls do not download gas app
like like you ever seen the show you on
Netflix
say no more and it's like it's like the
people are just spreading this thing and
so it's like what the hell like where is
this coming from and he doesn't know and
he's like it's got to be a competitor
and we're like okay what like what kind
of combat I mean you've just launched
like two weeks ago how are they doing
this coordinated like social like psyops
attack on you and your user base and
he's like then he's like we've we've
located the source of the hoax uh or or
it originated in China
he's like well here's what he says
here's what he says it's this is the
most official tweet ever it's so funny
he goes after an investigation our team
found several indications that the gas
app that uh the gas app human
trafficking hoax was planted by an
entity or person originating in China
our data shows users connecting from
China when the app first began growing
and the fake fake review the first fake
review were posted that same day and so
basically he's accusing something or
someone in China who starts she's
accusing the country yeah and so this is
just taking off from I want to make 10
million dollars I want to get in and get
out to China is trying to actively bring
me down and he just tweeted out dude I
am calling for a total and complete ban
of Chinese Goods in entering the United
no I'm just joking
you need to go lean in way more because
what he's doing in his PR push he's like
the the the the hoax the false hoax is
being spread about gas app human you
know trafficking blah blah blah and um
and I'm like bro you need to go full
Trump you need to be like China the
China virus is trying to take down this
American success gas app is it you know
Tick Tock is not only stealing your data
they're trying to take us down because
we are the number one app for teens
China is doing this this is anti-china I
was like you should be leaning in way
more to this child I was like I don't
know if it's true not true but like this
is your only hope is to get this like
you should stop saying your app's name
with the words you know human
trafficking and you should start saying
uh you know why is China trying to you
know spread fake news about this that is
that is my my official recommendation to
you and it's and it's totally working
and so this entire story that we just
spent 30 minutes on this entire story
we're talking like 20 days and this is
the roller coaster that we've been in
and he would say what he says today yes
but that's my point he says these things
in this group chat and when it's on your
phone when it's just on this small thing
you think this is just limited to us six
guys in this thing this is just no big
deal but then you turn on Fox Business
News and our Fox News business and he's
on there you go to Wall Street Journal
and he's on there you go to Business
Insider uh Bloomberg all these places
and it's real I go to tick tock and I
open up and there's a video about this
app and basically
as much as I don't like saying this
because I like Nikita but he is so smug
he has 100 called his shot and he hit it
he nailed it this is this is one of the
most epic stories that I've seen behind
the scenes in real time in a very long
time it's been quite amazing to watch
this entire thing play out in just 20
days yeah he's smoke as hell but I uh
you know the same reason I find Conor
McGregor very entertaining in the UFC
right this cocky guy who tries to call
his shots and then tries to pull it off
like
um I I'm thoroughly entertained and I'm
here for the entertainment uh and like
you know good for him made it happen
this this matters to him he got really
pumped about this and he made it happen
and it's like I feel like you know you
know Bane when he's like uh you know he
sees other people like you know I felt
like Nikita for like four years would
see other people try to build social
apps and he would just like on them
or he would be like uh you know or
people building apps and be like you
know if your app doesn't let you you
know flirt with someone buddy it's never
gonna work you know like or be like
unless you built the number one app in
the app store like you know don't talk
to me type of type of attitude and um
and I find it you know pretty awesome
that like you know like Bane when he's
like oh you know you know whatever the
line is he's like you know you uh you
you trained in the dark I was born in
the dark like that's him with these like
teen viral apps he's like you know oh
you're trying to make a social lap I was
born to make social apps
the fact that he just relaunched the
save app is hilarious to me in so many
ways um he probably had just like a
countdown timer to like when the
non-compete ends
because I talked to him in between and
he was considering all these like other
ideas you're considering this one real
estate idea it's considered this other
idea and then it was just like like
you know it's sort of all like Harry
Potter the wand chooses the wizard it's
like it's just pulling me back in just
what I think I'm out I gotta go do this
app again like
who fucker's Really Gonna Let do this
again
and then he did it again yeah this is
pretty amazing it also goes to show that
uh it shows a few things it kind of
breaks a lot of narratives which I
actually like which is a
like you don't really need like a
mission you know all the time like and
and I think that like with us you don't
need a noble mission
10 million dollars for three months
that's a great Mission and I do actually
think that maybe there is something
we're like oh it makes teens feel good
or whatever maybe that's like there but
like I think what's there really above
all else is get big fast because that's
exciting and just like play the puzzle
it's just a puzzle and I think that
that's like kind of the dominating
Factor behind what's driving him and I
think that that's the funny thing he
goes on Fox News and he's like doing the
interview you know they have the person
talking and then the background they're
showing screenshots of the app and so
he's saying he's like well the thing we
wanted to do was bring positivity to
teens you know teens feel really bad
from whatever like you know Instagram
what positivity wanted an app where
there's you know it's Anonymous but
there's no bullying there's no um
there's no like sort of negativity and
the screenshot is a poll question that
says want to steal them from their
boyfriend it's like okay
he's like you know we just want it he's
like I get messages every day from teens
saying you know uh you know I was gonna
do something bad to myself but this app
came out and now you know I'm running
around in a field full of uh flowers and
it's like it was just hilarious the
whole thing is is like straight Silicon
Valley uh HBO show like it's so funny to
me it is so funny and it's so exciting
another thing is that basically when
you're building these apps like the
really good folks are just like maniacal
about these little small numbers and
just tweaking them and just just being
obsessed with these little small things
when most people are carried about or
worrying about design or branding or the
logo or just these things that don't
matter it's like dude all I care about
is making this K Factor like more than
one and so and when it's not when it's
0.99 it's we're screwed we gotta totally
redo this and I just thought that it's a
really interesting story and this has
been like a roller coaster and one of
the cool things that's happened in a
long time I just love following along
this yeah props to him uh great great
job thank you for the thank you for the
entertainment
um all right do you want to do any more
or should we save it for the next I'll
tell you in one more I do have one more
but
um we should save that one it sounds too
interesting okay let's save it same for
the next one that's it we're out of here
[Music]